so T Fu's lawyer called me a few times
last week and let's just say he is not
particularly impressed with phase clans
recent lawsuit against his client T foo
he even called parts of that lawsuit
laughable and he described it to me as
an absolute gift
ooh that's a yikes now why is he so agro
about it well we're about to find out
plus I have a brand new statement from
faze clans own CEO on their counter suit
against - okay so a few weeks ago we put
out a video breakdown of faze clans
recent lawsuit against Turner Tenny make
AAT foo the guy who was formerly their
biggest streaming star until he sued
them back in May now I gave you a pretty
bird's-eye view of the complaint but
since then I've had a little bit more
time to dive into the lawsuit and some
of the details surrounding it I've gone
over the complaint and compared it to
faze clans previous statements and like
I said before I've had a chance to talk
to Brian Friedman T Fu's lawyer and
spoiler alert he is not impressed after
I read the complaint I actually had to
check the date on the calendar because I
thought it was Christmas I thought
somebody had actually given my client a
present because this complaint filed in
New York is an absolute gift so when I
first read phase Glen's lawsuit against
chief ooh I noticed a couple wonky
things some things that were
inconsistent with the tweets and the
videos they put out leading up to this
time but what T Fu's lawyer actually
told me is those inconsistencies could
actually matter not just in the court of
public opinion but in a court of law now
before we get into the first point we're
gonna cover three main inconsistencies
with the lawsuit versus their public
communications namely the idea that
phase was quote blindsided by the
lawsuit which was represented to the
public before they filed it the
messaging around collecting or not
collecting certain revenues from T foo
and the fact that they're allegedly
suing him for causing the gamer
agreement to leave now before we get
into that first point I want to say that
of course I did contact faze clan to try
and get as much of their voice in this
video as I could and unfortunately they
said they're not going to do interviews
around this lawsuit but I did get a
statement from the
CEO Lee trick pertaining to it which I
want to read part of now faze clan has
tried to maintain a positive
relationship with Tenny since April 2018
teddy was twenty years old when he
negotiated and signed a three-year
rookie gamer agreement with us the
relationship started off well and under
phase clans guidance
teni started having tremendous success
in game and otherwise as his notoriety
grew conversations began around
renegotiation we offered several revised
versions of his rookie contract in good
faith while we helped build his brand
and audience amongst the terms we
offered were a seven-figure salary bonus
and no revenue splits for faze clan at
all he rejected every offer despite how
we value Tenny as one of our rising
stars it became clear that he did not
want real negotiations he simply wants
to take the knowledge faze clan has
imparted to him and the audience we've
helped him build and compete against us
teni is in breach of his gamer agreement
he has publicly disparaged faze clan
stolen faze cleanse confidential
information interfered with faze cleanse
contracts and business relationships and
advocated for others to leave and
compete against our organization finally
drink had this to say we prefer not to
be involved in litigation but since
we're left no choice faze clan will
defend what is right and will hold Tenny
accountable for his choices and actions
we'll come back to that statement a few
times later but for now that is phase
clans perspective on the lawsuit now on
to our first inconsistency so Ricky
banks aka faze banks is a reported owner
of faze clan and he's kind of the
figurehead of the brand when we think of
basically an ownership or management we
all pretty much think of faze banks now
right after T Fu's lawsuit against faze
clan was made public banks adopted a
public facing stance of being shocked
being blindsided being surprised when I
say public facing I'm not trying to
suggest that it was strategic I think he
authenticated as much in his tweets and
in a video entitled dirty food that he
released shortly after this whole thing
erupted and I got no heads-up I got
absolutely no warning of this this is
something that could have easily been
handled offline and if this was just
about making even more
than you do now and we could have gotten
to that point to dude like I don't
understand it doesn't make any sense to
me now we later learned that phase had
been in a contract dispute with T foo
since September of 2018 phase clans
lawsuit itself makes it clear that
negotiations between phase and T foo
weren't going well for a very long time
leading up to the lawsuit saying quote
phase clay and value Tennys
contributions to the organization so it
made numerous proposals to renegotiate
the game or agreement and give Tenny the
contractual right to receive more
revenue teni rejected all the face
cleanse offers end quote in that
statement from lead shrink which I read
to you a few minutes ago he reiterated
the same point saying that it became
clear t f-- who didn't want to negotiate
and he just wanted to leave the branch
so if you're in a situation where you've
been going back and forth with the guy
over the last six plus months
renegotiating trying to get him new
contracts and all you've been met with
is either silence or rejection it seems
strange then to come out publicly and
describe your reaction to the lawsuit as
a complete shock now from phase clans
perspective the lawsuit also says that
they had just done a brand deal with T
few a few days before he sued them so
perhaps it's reasonable to say that that
little bit of cooperation gave them some
hope that the relationship could be
salvaged
speaking of brand deals one of the more
sort of obvious inconsistencies at least
when I read the lawsuit was the language
and the messaging around what revenue
they're collecting from T foo and how
the problem is this we have this
consistent messaging from all of phase
claim leading up to this point where
they're saying we're not interested in
monies or revenue directly taken from T
foo the value that he brings to the
brand comes with him just being on the
brand and that message has come through
again and again and again over the last
several months every statement phase has
made up until this point keeps hammering
home that they've collected zero dollars
from his content zero dollars from the
social media channel and just zero
dollars from his prize winnings and the
only thing they took from him was that
sixty thousand dollar figure lead shrink
said as much in an audio/video statement
released in May because we wanted Turner
to
feel that we had his back we made the
decision to not collect any money under
the under the old agreement nothing from
prizepool nothing from YouTube nothing
from anything except for a couple of
brand deals that accepted that we only
took 20% and those deals came from us to
him so it's really unfortunate that
we're here at all the relationship with
T Phu was much more important than the
money we gave him so many different
options that had little or even some of
them had no money going to faze clan and
yet we still couldn't get a deal done
and we come to find that the reason why
is he never plan on getting a deal done
with us he wanted to start a competing
organization and that's like the Lakers
letting LeBron James create a competing
NBA team they would never let it happen
and we should never let that happen
and faze banks made it very clear on
Twitter and elsewhere that the goal was
always just to retain T foo to keep T
foo on faze clan and not the money
directly taken from it that messaging
kind of gets blown up by this lawsuit
which is of course seeking to enforce
collection of all the funds that t foo
made throughout his time on faze clan
plus extra monetary damages for the
alleged wrongdoings of T through t Fu's
lawyer sees this inconsistency as a
stark contrast between what faze clan
represents publicly and what they
represent to a court of law
what's the truth and what's the lie you
tell your community that you told Turner
that you're not intending to collect any
monies under the contract you
specifically say it has tweaked to the
community to have the community trust
your word that you are not going to
collect any monies under the contract if
that was never your intention and that
you specifically told Turner that and
that Turner relied on that yet you file
a lawsuit in New York saying that not
only are you intending to collect that
money but you accuse Turner of secretin
away millions of dollars without telling
them well which is the truth is the
truth what you represented to the
community
that you never intended to collect that
money into the contract or the truth
what you filed in a lawsuit that you
want every single dollar under that
contract the very contracts that the
leader of your organization state bank
said was trash prepared by a [ __ ]
organization now in that last bit
Friedman is referring to a series of now
deleted tweets from phaz banks where he
calls T Fu's original Gamer agreement
the one they're suing to enforce quote
trash he said in that deleted tweet
quote I've made the mistake of allowing
[ __ ] people to run my business
we've solved those issues and are trying
our best the contract was trash there's
no denying that
end quote in another deleted tweet he
called teeth whose contract quote
horrible so again now faze clan find
themselves in the strange position where
they are suing to enforce a contract
they themselves called trash it's not a
good look
but look do we catch faze banks and some
giant lie is he gonna go to jail for
deleting these tweets no but what we do
have to consider is how these perceived
inconsistencies may affect how a judge
processes and rules on this lawsuit when
and if it actually gets to a court and
will touch on that specific point a
little later in this video but first one
more inconsistency faze clan is suing t
foo in part for directly or indirectly
causing the release of his original
gamer agreement now we don't actually
know who released the contract although
I have my suspicions but it's a little
strange again for faze clan to attack T
foo for allegedly causing the release of
the gamer agreement when faze banks
vowed to do exactly that many times just
for a quick refresher a bank said by the
way we are indeed releasing the contract
just got off the phone with the
higher-ups and we're preparing it for
you guys now we are releasing the
contract momentarily our legal team is
preparing everything we will release the
contract with all the context in the
world when we can all the sweets I just
read were published on may 22nd on may
23rd a web site called the blast leaked
the contract from an anonymous source
again T Fu's lawyer Brian Friedman does
not mince words when it comes to how he
feels about this situation in
assistant if they lie and it is another
reason that case plan is either
misrepresented something to its
community or is now misrepresenting
something to the court were you lying
then or are you lying now now of course
it needs to be said that T foo leaking
his own gamer agreement and faze clan
releasing it are legally probably two
different things and right now you might
be sitting there saying to yourself well
Colin I agree that some of the messaging
seems inconsistent with the lawsuit but
are we talking about a legal argument
here or a moral argument well I put that
exact question to Friedman because I'm
not a lawyer I'm not a judge and I am
NOT an expert in California or New York
law and I wasn't sure how much a bad
look could actually affect a legal case
like this now he wasn't willing to give
me his whole legal strategy of course
but he did tell me that these kind of
inconsistencies can actually negatively
affect the success of a lawsuit in a
court of law
now before we roll this clip keep in
mind that obviously Freedman is going to
be likely framing these answers in a way
that's beneficial to his cause he is a
lawyer out there after all and he is
trying to win his case what it is is
inconsistent what it is is a gift and
there will be a moment in time whether
it's in deposition or in trial the phase
will have to face the music and decide
were they lying to the community or are
they lying to a court okay one last
point and it's not necessarily an
inconsistency but it's one of the most
fascinating things about this case at
least from my perspective and that's the
question of where litigation for both
these lawsuits should take place you
guys already know that faze clan suti
foo in New York and T foo sued phase
plan in California and we've been over
the basic facts of this before the game
or agreement says that all litigation
has to take place in New York but that
Clause could very well be completely
unenforceable face cleanse principle
business is located in California
they're incorporated in Delaware and T
foods from Florida so nothing really has
anything to do with New York there again
perhaps unsurprisingly Freedman makes it
clear that in his view the fact that
Bay's plan filed their lawsuit in New
York speaks
volumes about their lack of confidence
around litigation in California what the
real fact is that face plant has asked
the Labor Commissioner to try and delay
that case to try to avoid
responsibilities for violating
California talent agency act by
operating as an unlicensed talent agency
they're trying to avoid judgment day in
the state of California by picking a
jurisdiction of New York that has
nothing to do with anything other than
to allow them to violate California law
okay before you stop recording I have a
message for the comment section these
papers that we hold up this is my script
this is real we do not have a
teleprompter and I do not tape anything
to the front of the camera all right see
you next time I guess